When we think about dishonesty, we mostly think about the big stuff. I did not have sexual relations with that woman. We're thousands and thousands of people. We're cheering as that building was coming down. Thousands of people. I said it for longer than seven years. I have never doped. The answer is I did not send that tweet.
当我们想到不诚 dishonest 时，我们通常会想到大事。“我没有和那个女人发生性关系。”“我们有成千上万的人。当那栋大楼倒塌时，我们在欢呼。成千上万的人。”“我隐瞒了七年多。我从未服用兴奋剂。”“答案是我没有发送那条推文。”
My system was hacked. I was pranked. It was a fairly he goes hey I know a way that we can both make a little bit of money. You give me information. I'm gonna trade on it. I will split it three ways. This kind of dishonesty seems so blatant. So wrong. And you said yourself wow I could have never done this. Like this is a different kind of a person. That's not me. I can't possibly be like that person. This is Dan Ariely, researcher and author of the book,
“我的系统被黑了。我被恶作剧了。”这是一场相当……他说：“嘿，我知道一个我们俩都能赚点小钱的方法。你给我信息。我要根据它进行交易。我将分成三份。”这种不诚实看起来如此公然。如此错误。你自己也说：“哇，我绝对做不出这种事。就像这是一个不同类型的人。那不是我。我绝不可能成为那样的人。”这是丹·艾瑞里（Dan Ariely），研究员兼书的作者，
The Honest Truth About Disonesty, How We Lie To Everyone, Especially Our Cells. Dan says the truth about dishonesty might surprise you. What separates honest people from not honest people is not necessarily character, it's opportunity. We also talk about Dan's personal life and what a life-threatening injury taught him about deception and self-deception. It's kind of embarrassing. Do we have to talk about that? Can we talk about something else? Yes. Dan Ariali is a professor of psychology and behavioral economics at Duke University. He is the author of the book, The Honest Truth about Disonesty.
《诚实的真相：关于不诚实，我们如何对所有人说谎，尤其是对自己》（The (Honest) Truth About Dishonesty: How We Lie to Everyone—Especially Ourselves）。丹说，关于不诚实的真相可能会让你感到意外。区分诚实的人与不诚实的人的，不一定是品格，而是机会。我们还谈到了丹的个人生活，以及一次生死攸关的受伤教会了他关于欺骗和自我欺骗的什么。这有点尴尬。我们一定要谈这个吗？我们能谈点别的吗？可以。丹·艾瑞里是杜克大学的心理学和行为经济学教授。他是《诚实的真相》一书的作者。
Dan, welcome to Hidden Brain. My pleasure, so nice to be here. Dan, with many Americans thinking about their taxes right now, I want to start with a counterintuitive question. Why don't more people cheat on their taxes? Most of us know the IRS is overwhelmed and overstretched, so rationally, more people are to get away with cheating than actually do.
丹，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我的荣幸，很高兴来到这里。丹，鉴于许多美国人现在都在考虑他们的税务问题，我想从一个违反直觉的问题开始。为什么没有更多的人在税收上作弊？我们大多数人都知道美国国税局（IRS）不堪重负、人手不足，所以从理性上讲，更多的人本可以侥幸逃税，而实际上却没有这么做。
Well, first of all, just by saying it, maybe you've increased the proportion of people who cheat this year, so maybe you contribute to the issue. But the truth is that you're absolutely right. When we look at this honesty, we often look at the half-empty part of the glass and we look at all the things that people do badly, but the reality is that we are really quite wonderful. We don't have to go all the way to Texas. We can think about all kinds of other cases. So in the last few years, almost every time I go to a restaurant, I ask the waiter if there's a way to eat and
嗯，首先，仅仅通过这样说，也许你已经提高了今年作弊的人的比例，所以也许你是在助长这个问题。但事实是，你是完全正确的。当我们看待不诚实时，我们经常看到杯子空了一半的那部分，我们看着人们做得不好的所有事情，但现实是，我们实际上相当不错。我们不必一直扯到德克萨斯州（译者注：此处谐音梗或口误，原文All the way to taxes/Texas）。我们可以想想其他各种各样的例子。所以在过去的几年里，几乎每次我去餐馆时，我都问服务员有没有办法吃完饭
escape without paying. And you know, sometimes I get strange look, sometimes they ask me for my credit cards, but they always give me good advice. They say things like wait for a big party to come, go to the bathroom, there's an alley, I mean, they have suggestions of how to escape without paying. And then I ask them how often does it happen? And they say very rarely.
然后逃单而不付钱。你知道的，有时我会得到奇怪的眼神，有时他们会向我要信用卡，但他们总是给我好建议。他们会说诸如“等一个大聚会来的时候”、“去洗手间，那里有一条小巷”之类的话，我的意思是，他们有关于如何逃单而不付钱的建议。然后我问他们这种情况多久发生一次？他们说非常罕见。
And in fact, they say sometimes people leave the restaurant without paying because, you know, we forget whether we pay or not pay we don't pay attention and people call back and pay over the phone. So there's a lot of goodness in us and in fact the surprising thing for a rational economist would be why don't people steal more right why why don't we take advantage. So we do have some internal moral conscience. We have internalized the values of society and we don't need anybody around us. We don't need prison sentences. We don't need to be afraid. We make our own judgment of what's right and wrong and we adhere to those decisions. Not perfectly, but to a
事实上，他们说有时人们离开餐馆时没有付钱，因为，你知道的，我们忘记了我们是否付过钱，或者我们没有付钱，我们没有注意，然后人们会打电话回来并通过电话付款。所以我们身上有很多善良，事实上，对于一个理性的经济学家来说，令人惊讶的事情将是：为什么人们不偷更多东西？对吧？为什么我们不利用这一点？所以我们确实有一些内部的道德良知。我们已经将社会的价值观内化了，我们不需要身边的任何人。我们不需要判刑。我们不需要害怕。我们对什么是对、什么是错做出自己的判断，并且我们坚持这些决定。虽然不完美，但在很大程度上是这样的。
very large degree. One of the things that I find interesting about what you're saying is that in some ways people are often unthinkingly honest. In other words, they're not actually asking themselves what room do I have to be dishonest. They're actually honest just because it's a rule that they're following. And of course, much of your work has focused on the flip side of that, which is that people are also unthinkingly dishonest. It's not just people who are trying to be dishonest, but people who are making small lapses, small slips without really thinking about it very clearly. That's exactly right. And when we think about this honesty, we often think about kind of big cases of people who've done terrible things. And in the research on this honesty, we've done lots of lab experiments, but we've also interviewed 40 big cheaters. But what was so
关于你所说的话，我觉得有趣的一点是，在某些方面，人们往往是不经思考地诚实。换句话说，他们实际上并没有问自己：我有多大空间可以不诚实？他们其实很诚实，仅仅因为那是他们正在遵循的一条规则。当然，你的许多工作都集中在那枚硬币的另一面上，也就是人们也是不经思考地不诚实。这不仅是那些试图不诚实的人，而且是那些犯下小失误、小差错而没有真正非常清楚地思考过的人。完全正确。当我们想到这种不诚实时，我们经常想到那些做了可怕事情的人的大案件。在关于不诚实的研究中，我们做了大量的实验室实验，但我们也采访了40名大作弊者。但如此
interesting about these discussions is without exception, all of them, when you talk to these people and you try to figure out how did they get to where they got, and you say to yourself, wow, I could have never done this. Like this is a different kind of a person. That's not me. I can't possibly be like that person. But when instead, you asked these people to tell you what was their first step. What was the first thing they did? You can say to yourself, I could have done that. I could have seen myself in that case. And I can give you one example. One of the guys we talked to, his name is Joe Pepp. And Joe was a cyclist. He loved cycling, he loved nothing else in the world, but cycling.
有趣的是这些讨论，无一例外，当与这些人交谈并试图弄清楚他们是如何走到今天这一步时，你会对自己说：“哇，我永远不可能做到这一点。就像这是一个不同类型的人。那不是我。我绝不可能成为那样的人。”但相反，当你要求这些人告诉你他们的第一步是什么。他们做的第一件事是什么？你可以对自己说：“我本可以做到这一点。我能在那种情况下看到我自己。”我可以给你举个例子。我们交谈过的一个家伙，他的名字叫乔·帕普（Joe Papp）。乔是一名自行车手。他热爱自行车，他对世界上别无所爱，除了自行车。
He was in the Olympic team, the American Olympic team, and then at some point he went back to school to finish his degree. After a few years went back to cycling, he goes on this race, but he feels that everybody else is slightly faster. And he's incredibly frustrated and he cries that night. And one of his friends says, here's a name for a doctor. He goes to see this doctor, white coat, and a status cope, and the doctor prescribes to him a EPO. EPO is a drug that people use for cancer that increases the production of red blood cells. Really good thing if you need energy, right? It means oxygen basically.
他曾入选奥运代表队，即美国奥运代表队，后来在某个时候他重返校园完成学业。几年后重返自行车运动，他参加了这场比赛，但他觉得其他所有人都稍微快一点。他感到难以置信的沮丧，那天晚上他哭了。他的其中一个朋友说，这里有一个医生的名字。他去看这位医生，医生穿着白大褂，拿着听诊器，医生给他开了一种EPO。EPO是人们用于癌症的药物，可以增加红细胞的产量。如果你需要精力，这真的是个好东西，对吧？它基本上意味着氧气。
He goes to the pharmacy, he gives him the prescription, his insurance company pays for it, he pays the deductible, he takes it to his apartment, he gives himself the first injection, then the next day, the next injection and so on, eventually it's a habit. Then he moves to another team, he finds out that everybody else is doing it, they do it more publicly. Anyway things continue, then there's a shortage of EPO. But he has a friend that has connection in China, on a Chinese team, and he puts them in touch with a Chinese factory who produces EPO.
他去药房，把处方交给他，他的保险公司支付了费用，他支付了自付额，他把它带到他的公寓，他给自己注射了第一针，然后是第二天，下一针，等等，最终这成了一种习惯。然后他转到另一个团队，他发现其他人都在这样做，他们做得更公开。无论如何，事情继续着，然后EPO短缺了。但他有一个朋友在中国有关系，在中国的一个团队里，他让他们与生产EPO的中国工厂取得了联系。
He imports EPO for himself. Then his friends find out about it and ask him to import for them as well, so import for them as well. Eventually, he's a drug dealer. Now if you just look at Joe Pepp and you say, could I ever become a drug dealer who imports EPO, you would say no. But when you look at the first step, you would ask yourself, where exactly would we stop?
他为自己进口EPO。然后他的朋友们发现了这一点，并要求他也为他们进口，所以也为他们进口。最终，他成了一个毒贩。现在，如果你只看乔·帕普，然后你说，我有没有可能成为一个进口EPO的毒贩？你会说不会。但是当你看着第一步时，你会问自己，我们究竟会在哪里停下来？
Imagine yourself in his shoes. Like it's the first day, you just came back to cycling, you do just as well as you thought you could, everybody's faster. Don't you cry? Of course you do. A friend gives you an address for a physician. Don't you go? Of course you do. A friend gives you an address for a physician. Don't you go? Of course you do. The physician gives you a prescription. Don't you go to fill it? Of course you do.
把自己想象成他的鞋子。就像第一天，你刚回到自行车运动，你做得和你想象的一样好，每个人都更快。你难道不哭吗？你当然会哭。一个朋友给你一个医生的地址。你难道不去吗？你当然会去。一个朋友给你一个医生的地址。你难道不去吗？你当然会去。医生给你开了一个处方。你难道不去抓药吗？你当然会去。
You get the prescription, you have all these injections. Don't you try once? Of course you do. I mean, when exactly would we stop? And one of the frightening conclusions we have is that what separates honest people from not honest people is not necessarily character, it's opportunity. Right? And if we were all in Joe's shoes, maybe we would have all been like this, exactly like that. One of the things that caught my eye recently, Dan, is that you had a paper that actually explores this very idea from the point of view of science, and this study remarkably was actually looking at how the brain operates as people were making these little deceptions. Yeah, so the brain is really a mechanism for detecting surprising things, right?
你拿到了处方，你做了所有这些注射。你难道不想尝试一次吗？你当然会。我的意思是，我们究竟会在什么时候停下来？我们得出的可怕结论之一是，区分诚实的人和不诚实的人的，不一定是品格，而是机会。对吧？如果我们都处在乔的立场上，也许我们都会像这样，完全像那样。丹，最近引起我注意的一件事情是，你有一篇论文实际上从科学的角度探讨了这个确切的想法，而这项研究引人注目的是，它实际上是在观察人们在做出这些小骗局时大脑是如何运作的。是的，所以大脑确实是一个检测令人惊讶的事物的机制，对吧？
The brain is basically working on adaptation. You get to a certain level of light in the beginning, it's surprising, and then you get used to that environment. And this is true across lots of things that the brain does. It turns out that the brain also reacts very strongly to a first act of lying, but then as we keep on lying more and more, the brain kind of stops reacting to it.
大脑基本上是在适应的基础上工作的。一开始你达到了某种光线水平，这令人惊讶，然后你习惯了那个环境。对于大脑所做的许多事情来说，这都是真的。事实证明，大脑对第一次说谎的反应也非常强烈，但随着我们不断地撒谎越来越多，大脑对它的反应就会停止。
So we start by being aware of this, maybe being at this honest act, and we at least are aware of it, maybe being at this honest act, and we at least aware of it, but over time it just goes into the background and we don't pay attention to it. Hmm. You've made the case in several books and articles that lying in deception is not usually about, you know, a rational cost-benefit equation where people are balancing the advantages of deception against the risk of getting caught,
所以我们一开始意识到这一点，也许是在进行这种不诚实的行为，我们至少意识到了这一点，也许是在进行这种不诚实的行为，我们至少意识到了这一点，但随着时间的推移，它只是进入了背景，我们没有注意到它。嗯。你在几本书和文章中提出过这样的观点：谎言和欺骗通常不是关于，你知道的，一种理性的成本收益等式，在这种等式中，人们权衡欺骗的好处与被抓的风险，
but about something that you call the fudge factor. What's the fudge factor? Yeah, so the cost-benefit analysis, by the way, is the kind of the standard framework in economics, right? You say to yourself, how likely might you get caught? What will happen to me?
而是关于你所谓的“模糊因子”（fudge factor）。什么是模糊因子？是的，顺便说一句，成本效益分析是经济学中的标准框架，对吧？你对自己说：你被抓的可能性有多大？我会发生什么？
What can I get away with? How much can I steal? And you basically do a cost benefit analysis. We find that those things don't really matter. What we find that matters is this intricate balance between wanting to get a bit more selfishly, wanting a bit more right now. I wish I had a bit more money, I wish I had more prestige, whatever it is. And on the other hand, wanting to look at ourselves in the mirror and feel that we're good honest people.
我能侥幸逃脱什么？我能偷多少？你基本上是在做一个成本效益分析。我们发现这些事情其实并不重要。我们发现重要的是这种错综复杂的平衡：一方面想要更自私一点，想要现在多一点。我希望我能多一点钱，我希望我有更多的声望，无论它是什么。另一方面，想要看着镜子里的自己，觉得自己是善良诚实的人。
We can cheat a little bit and still feel good about ourselves. So for example, if you're on a 65 mile an hour road, if you're at 68, you don't think you're speeding. So we have this ability to rationalize our actions and to basically say, yes, you know, under FBI interrogation, I would realize this is not the perfect truth, but it's okay. There's still a reason for it. I can still rationalize.
我们可以作弊一点点，但依然对自己的感觉很好。例如，如果你在一条限速65英里的路上，如果你开到68英里，你不会认为你在超速。所以我们有这种能力来合理化我们的行为，并且基本上说，是的，你知道的，在联邦调查局的审讯下，我会意识到这不是完全的真相，但没关系。它仍然有理由。我仍然可以合理化。
I can still explain what it is, especially when we don't think about it too carefully. Let's talk a little bit about solutions. You think that one of the things that the IRS should ask taxpayers to do is to fill out a testimonial that says, I declare that everything I say here will be the truth, only the truth. Nothing but the truth, so help me, God. Why do you think personal testimonials might be useful when people are filling out their tax returns?
我仍然可以解释它是什么，尤其是当我们没有太仔细地思考它的时候。让我们多谈谈解决方案。你认为国税局应该要求纳税人做的一件事是填写一份证明，上面写着：“我声明我在这里所说的一切都将是真相，只有真相。毫无保留的真相，上帝保佑我。”为什么你认为个人证明在人们填写纳税申报表时可能会有用？
Yeah, so first of all, we have data. I'll tell you about it in a second. But think about our oral tradition. When people go to court, we have data, I'll tell you about it in a second, but think about our oral tradition. When people go to court, we swear in the beginning, right? And we swear in the beginning, not because we think we know already everything we've said, but we swear in the beginning because we understand, as a society, as an institution, that honesty is about the mindset. And you basically say, I swear, I'll say the truth, the whole truth and nothing, but the truth.
是的，所以首先，我们有数据。我一会儿会告诉你。但想想我们的口头传统。当人们上庭时，我们有数据，我一会儿会告诉你，但想想我们的口头传统。当人们上庭时，我们在开始时宣誓，对吧？我们在开始时宣誓，并不是因为我们认为我们已经知道了我们所说的一切，而是因为我们宣誓在开始时，是因为我们作为一个社会、作为一个机构理解，诚实是关于心态的。你基本上说，我发誓，我要说实话，全部的实话，毫无保留的实话。
And you put yourself into the state of being honest from now on. Now what happened that over the years, lawyers got into things. And instead of using the oral tradition, we sign at the end, right? Every document you sign at the end, not in the beginning. So all of a sudden, it's not about your mindset going in, it's about verification of the fact afterward. But you know what? When you get to the end, lying is over, it's done. Like imagine that you would test a fine court, and you wouldn't swear in the beginning, you would swear at the end.
你让自己进入了从现在开始要诚实的状态。现在发生的事情是，多年来，律师介入了事情。我们没有使用口头传统，而是在最后签字，对吧？你签名的每份文件都在最后，而不是在开始。所以突然之间，这不再是关于你进入时的心态，而是关于事后的事实验证。但你知道吗？当你走到最后时，说谎已经结束了，它已经完成了。就像想象一下，如果你在测试一个好的法庭，而你不是在开始时宣誓，而是在最后宣誓。
What? You would say, oh, oh, sorry, sorry, let me go back to the third thing I said that we changed my opinion. So what happened is that the legal tradition has kind of taken something that we all intuit, quite basically, that honesty is about the mindset and change it to verification. So that was the initial intuition for this. And we've done quite a few experiments. In one of them, we did it with a big insurance company. This was an insurance company that sends people letters that asked me how many miles did you drive last year? And if you drove more, you pay higher premium, you drove less, you pay lower premium, and people of course
什么？你会说：“哦，哦，抱歉，抱歉，让我回到我刚才说的第三件事情上，那改变了我的观点。”所以发生的事情是，法律传统有点把我们所有人都直观理解的东西——基本上，诚实是关于心态的——改成了验证。所以这是最初的直觉。我们做了相当多的实验。其中一个实验，我们与一家大型保险公司合作。这是一家向人们发送信件的保险公司，询问我去年开了多少英里？如果你开得更多，你支付更高的保费，你开得更少，你支付更低的保费，人们当然
have the incentive to declare that they drove less because then they would pay less. And they had the regular form, which you filled the numbers in, and you sign at the bottom of the form, and we created a new version of the form in which people sign in the beginning. And what we saw was that people drove more by 15% in the condition when they signed upfront. Wow. By the way, we've replicated it in all kinds of ways,
有动机声明他们开得更少，因为这样他们就会支付更少。他们有常规的表格，你在其中填写数字，并在表格底部签名，我们创建了该表格的新版本，人们在开头签名。我们看到的是，在人们提前签名的情况下，人们多开了15%的里程。哇。顺便说一句，我们在各种方面复制了它，
including with the procurement offices within the US government, including with taxes in a country in South America, and including with a traveler insurance in Northern Europe. In all of those cases, you get people to sign something, they get into kind of a different mental state. They remember honesty, we kind of guard ourselves against being dishonest and then people feel things in a more honest way. I'm not sure perfectly honest, but more honest way. And by the way, we started by looking at the glass half full part of it.
包括美国政府内部的采购办公室，包括南美洲某国的税收，以及包括北欧的旅行保险。在所有这些情况下，你让人们签署一些东西，他们进入了一种不同的精神状态。他们记住了诚实，我们某种程度上防范自己变得不诚实，然后人们以一种更诚实的方式感受到事情。我不敢说完全诚实，但更诚实的方式。顺便说一句，我们从杯子半满的部分开始看起。
This is a tremendously glass glassful story because it says we have the desire to be honest. Something about the education process gets people to want to be honest. We just need to remind people that they want to be honest and then it works. When we come back, I'm going to ask Diane about the virtues of deception and self-deception. Our case study, Dan Arieli, stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vitaantham. When Dan Arieli was 17 years old, he was at a graduation ceremony. Flares were being sent up to celebrate, and one went off too close to him.
这是一个非常令人充满希望的故事，因为它表明我们有渴望诚实的愿望。教育过程中的某些东西让人们想要诚实。我们只需要提醒人们他们想要诚实，然后它就起作用了。当我们回来时，我将询问黛安（译者注：此处主持人口误将Dan叫成Diane）关于欺骗和自我欺骗的美德。我们的案例研究对象是丹·艾瑞里，请继续收听。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。当丹·艾瑞里17岁时，他在参加一个毕业典礼。人们燃放照明弹来庆祝，其中一枚离他太近而爆炸了。
70% of his body was burned and he spent the next three years in a hospital. This story is hard to listen to, but Dan's injuries and the experiences he had with doctors and nurses reveal a lot about human behavior. And they changed the way Dan came to think about deception and self-deception. It turns out that severe burns that cover all of your body don't go away. I didn't know it at the time, but I'm more than 30 years later now, and my last surgery was last year. It's a gift that keeps on giving.
他身体的70%被烧伤，在接下来的三年里他在医院度过。这个故事很难听，但丹的伤势以及他与医生和护士的经历揭示了许多关于人类行为的事情。它们改变了丹对欺骗和自我欺骗的看法。事实证明，覆盖你全身的严重烧伤是不会消失的。我当时并不知道，但现在已经是30多年后了，我的最后一次手术是在去年。这是一份不断送出“礼物”的经历。
It's a very, very difficult injury, a lot of pain in the beginning, very hard to recover, and then it keeps on, I mean, the challenges are just ongoing. So you get to the hospital, you're spending many weeks in the hospital, you're obviously in great pain, various operations and procedures are being performed on you. The doctors share with you how badly off you were? No, so first of all, I was in a hospital for almost three years in total. In the beginning, of course, all burn patients above 30% are kind of a risk of losing their lives and nobody told me that. I actually don't think anybody really told me exactly what to expect. But no, I didn't know how long it will be, I didn't know how painful it will be, I didn't understand
这是一次非常非常困难的受伤，开始时有很多疼痛，很难恢复，然后它一直在继续，我的意思是，挑战一直在继续。所以你到了医院，你在医院度过了许多星期，你显然处于巨大的痛苦中，各种手术和程序正在对你进行。医生与你分享了你的情况有多糟糕吗？没有，所以首先，我总共在医院呆了将近三年。一开始，当然，所有超过30%的烧伤病人都面临失去生命的风险，没有人告诉我这一点。我其实觉得没有人真正确切地告诉我该期待什么。但没有，我不知道会持续多久，我不知道会有多痛苦，我不懂
what burns are. Nobody actually gave me this, you know, really sad view of how the future will evolve from the perspective of the burns now As somebody who studies dishonesty and deception and who has made a very strong case against deception You found yourself paradoxically looking back in hindsight thinking that maybe the doctors did the right thing that maybe they did the right thing by deceiving you and maybe you helped in that deception with a certain amount of self-deception as well. Yeah, and like everybody who gets injured in a deep way, I also contemplated terminating my life. I didn't have much power to do it,
什么是烧伤。没有人真正给我这种，你知道的，关于未来如何从现在的烧伤角度演变的可怕看法。作为一个研究不诚实和欺骗、并且对欺骗提出了非常强烈的反对意见的人，你发现自己矛盾地回首往事，认为也许医生做了正确的事，也许他们通过欺骗你做了正确的事，也许你在那种欺骗中也通过一定程度的自我欺骗提供了帮助。是的，就像每个遭受严重伤害的人一样，我也曾考虑过结束我的生命。我没有太大的权力去这样做，
but I certainly thought about that. And I think that if I had at the time a more objective view of what the future would hold, I might have tried to do that. So that's kind of on a big philosophical kind of meaning of life kind of part, but it also shows up in smaller ways. So I remember one surgery.
但我当然考虑过这一点。我认为，如果当时我对未来有一个更客观的看法，我可能会尝试这样做。所以这有点像在对生活意义的宏大哲学层面，但它也以较小的方式出现。所以I记得有一次手术。
So this was a surgery to my right hand. And after the surgery, they couldn't put cast on my hand, of course, because it was the skin. You can't put cast on the skin. So instead, what they do is they put these metal nails through the bone to hold the fingers. So I had two nails coming from the side of my thumb and a nail coming in each finger throughout the whole finger.
所以这是对我的右手的手术。手术后，他们当然不能在我的手上打石膏，因为那是皮肤。你不能在皮肤上打石膏。相反，他们做的是将这些金属钉穿过骨头来固定手指。所以我大拇指侧面有两个钉子，每个手指贯穿整个手指都有一个钉子。
And you know, kind of basically lots of needles poking out. And by the way, at the end of them, they would put something so I wouldn't poke myself at night if I by mistake got my hand too close to my face. And the surgery was done. And six weeks later, they were going to take off these nails. And I asked the nurse, when are they going to schedule the operating room to take these out? And she said, oh, you know, don't worry about it. We're going to just take
你知道的，基本上有很多针头露出来。顺便说一句，在它们的末端，他们会放一些东西，这样如果我晚上不小心把手离脸太近，我就不会扎到自己。手术完成了。六周后，他们要拆掉这些钉子。我问护士，他们什么时候安排手术室来把这些取出来？她说：“哦，你知道的，不用担心。我们只会在
it out in the in the department. And I said, don't you have to put me to sleep for this? And she said, no, no, no, it doesn't hurt at all. And it turns out it really hurt. Now, it wasn't probably as bad as putting the nails in, but it was, it at all. And it turns out it really hurt. Now, it wasn't probably as bad as putting the nails in, but it was painful and it took a while to take these, I don't know, 15 nails or so. But think about the three weeks that I would have had agony of being afraid. This way, I had the same pain,
科室里把它们取出来。”我说：“你们不用让我麻醉吗？”她说：“不，不，不，一点也不疼。”事实证明它真的很疼。现在，它可能没有把钉子放进去那么糟糕，但它是痛苦的，花了很长时间才拔出这些，我不知道，15个左右的钉子。但想想我将因恐惧而经历三个星期的痛苦折磨。这样，我有了同样的痛苦，
but without the dread that came up with it. Now, do I justify lying? It's very tough, but do I recognize that it contributed to my well-being and that I would have had three weeks of, you know, I was terrified as it is. You know, when you're patient, your lack of control and fear is just incredible. You're just lying in bed and other people decide what to do with you, when to do with you. The helplessness is tremendous. And being, having the fear of people pulling these nails out of me, without anesthesia and being painful, probably would have been very, very difficult to take at the time, adding to that. So, I am grateful. I'm grateful. I still think it's a questionable decision, but I am grateful.
但没有随之而来的恐惧。现在，我为说谎辩护吗？这非常艰难，但我承认它对我的健康有贡献，而且我本会有三周的，你知道的，我当时已经吓坏了。你知道的，当你是一个病人时，你缺乏控制和恐惧是令人难以置信的。你只是躺在床上，其他人决定如何对你做，什么时候对你做。无助感是巨大的。而且拥有人们把这些钉子从我身上拔下来的恐惧，没有麻醉并且很痛苦，当时可能非常非常难以承受，这又增加了痛苦。所以，我很感激。我很感激。我仍然认为这是一个值得商榷的决定，但我很感激。
I believe that at another time, a nurse introduced you to another burn victim who had survived, and she meant for this to be encouraging, but in some ways it had the opposite effect on you. Yeah, this was maybe two or three months after my initial injury and at that point I could see and I could talk a little bit and so on. And they brought somebody who got injured and because I had no view of what my future would look like, I kind of imagined myself basically going back to regular life. I didn't understand everything that was happening. And when they brought this old patient to come, he was supposed to to symbol recovery. He was, I don't know, 15 years after his injury. He was supposed to symbolize
我相信在另一个时间，一位护士把你介绍给另一个幸存的烧伤受害者，她的本意是鼓励，但在某些方面它对你产生了相反的效果。是的，这可能是我最初受伤后两三个月，当时我可以看到并且可以说一点话等等。他们带来了某个受伤的人，因为我对我的未来会是什么样子没有概念，我有点想象自己基本上回到正常的生活。我并不明白正在发生的一切。当他们把这个老病人带来时，他本应象征着康复。他，我不知道，是他受伤后15年。他本应象征着
somebody who's made it. And he looked terrible with very severe burns. It was clear he didn't have functions of his hands. You know, everything I have now, right? So they were correct. But at that point, it was a shock to realize that this was the future that they were, like, optimistically I could hope for. I was hoping for a much more optimistic future than that.
成功的人。他看起来很糟糕，有非常严重的烧伤。很明显，他的手没有功能。你知道的，我现在拥有的一切，对吧？所以他们是对的。但当时，这是一个打击，意识到这就是他们认为的未来，乐观地说我可以希望的未来。我希望有一个比那更乐观的未来。
My own optimism was much higher than that reality. Even though they brought that patient to show me how life could turn out well, for me it was just a shock to the system. I'm wondering whether this experience helped shape the way you think about self-deception. Self-deception. You know, self-deception has been widely criticized, and obviously it has many consequences, adverse consequences, when we lie to ourselves.
我自己的乐观情绪远高于那个现实。尽管他们带来那个病人是为了向我展示生活如何能过得很好，但对我来说，这只是对系统的打击。我想知道这段经历是否塑造了你对自我欺骗的思考方式。自我欺骗。你知道的，自我欺骗一直受到广泛批评，显然，当我们对自己说谎时，它有很多后果，不良后果。
But many people have also made the case that if we don't lie to ourselves ever, life becomes often unbearably difficult, and not just when you're suffering from serious burns, but in all kinds of different ways we need to deceive ourselves to get through our day. What do you make of that argument? Look, there's no question that there's some truth to that argument. The question is how much of it, which is true for all questions about this honesty. It's true that this honesty is corrosive and destructive and terrible for society and so on. It's also true that we don't want to eliminate it completely. And the real question is dosage and under what conditions. And I can tell you that sometimes I think about my experience in the hospital,
但许多人也提出这样的观点：如果我们从来不对自己说谎，生活往往会变得难以忍受的困难，而且不仅是在你遭受严重烧伤时，而且在各种不同的方式中，我们需要欺骗自己来度过每一天。你怎么看这个论点？听着，毫无疑问这个论点有一定道理。问题在于有多少，这适用于关于不诚实的所有问题。诚实的说，不诚实具有腐蚀性、破坏性，对社会来说是可怕的，等等。同样真实的是，我们不想完全消除它。真正的问题是剂量和在什么条件下。我可以告诉你，有时我回想起我在医院的经历，
not just with deception, but with pain and with Medication and with placebo and with lack of control and so on. It's got a magnifying a glass and all kinds of things in life and including in deception and I I don't think I could have taken the physicians telling me exactly the truth. And a couple of years ago, I was asked to help a young guy who was burned and a relative of his asked me to send this kid an optimistic note about his future. And it was a tremendous torture for me,
不仅是关于欺骗，还有关于疼痛、药物、安慰剂和缺乏控制等等。它就像是一副放大镜，放大了生活中的各种事情，包括欺骗，我并不认为我能接受医生告诉我确切的真相。几年前，我被要求帮助一个被烧伤的年轻人，他的亲戚要求我给这个孩子发一张关于他未来的乐观便条。这对我来说是一种巨大的折磨，
because on one hand, I didn't think his future was going to be very optimistic. On the other hand, I didn't think it would be right to expose him to the full brutality of the many years that are going to be ahead of him. I debated for about two days while crying quite a lot about like what to tell him and what not to tell him and I've kind of brought myself back to what I wanted to know and not to know. And eventually I found some kind of compromise that I was okay with.
因为一方面，我不认为他的未来会非常乐观。另一方面，我认为让他暴露在未来多年来将要面临的全部残酷现实中是不对的。我争论了两天，哭了很多次，关于该告诉他什么，不该告诉他什么，我有点把自己带回到我想知道的和不想知道的事情上。最终我找到了一种我能接受的某种妥协。
But it was certainly not the brutal truth straight up. not the brutal truth straight up. I want to wrap up with a story that moves us forward by several years because I feel like this is a wonderful story that reveals so many different aspects about human nature, the nature of deception, the nature of self-deception, the complexity of human behavior. You were once at an airport confronting a very long line at check-in. Do you remember the story of what happened next? I remember, it's kind of embarrassing. Do we have to talk about that? Can we talk about something else? As your own research has shown then, thinking about the
但这绝对不是直言不讳的残酷真相。我希望用一个让我们向前推进几年的故事来结束，因为我觉得这是一个美好的故事，它揭示了关于人性的许多不同方面、欺骗的本质、自我欺骗的本质、人类行为的复杂性。你曾经在机场面对着值机时非常长的队伍。你还记得接下来发生的事情的故事吗？我记得，这有点尴尬。我们一定要谈这个吗？我们能谈点别的吗？正如你自己的研究所表明的那样，
stuff that's embarrassing can be very revealing. It is revealing. Yes. So, okay, we'll see where you go with this. You know, I have an injury, but I'm not that injured. Huge line, and I'm there with a friend, and I ask him to go and get me a wheelchair. And, you know, I have a hard time standing for a long time, but I don't need a wheelchair. And he got me a wheelchair, and we checked in very quickly, and we cheated. I mean, I, I, which he did, I cheated, got quickly in front of the line. But, but the second part of that story was that,
思考那些令人尴尬的事情可以非常有启迪意义。确实很有启迪意义。是的。好吧，我们会看看你把这个带向何方。你知道的，我受过伤，但我没有伤得那么重。巨大的队伍，我和一个朋友在那里，我请他去给我弄一把轮椅。你知道的，我很长时间站着有困难，但我不需要轮椅。他给我弄了一把轮椅，我们很快就办理了登机手续，我们作弊了。我的意思是，我，我，借由他，我作弊了，迅速排到了队伍的最前面。但是，但那个故事的第二部分是，
so now I'm in this wheelchair, waiting for the, for the flight, and I try to go to the bathroom. And of course, I try to go to the bathroom and of course I try to go to the bathroom with a wheelchair and the bathroom is just not designed for anybody With a wheelchair and I get really upset I get really upset that the bathroom is not designed for people in wheelchair Then it became worse Because then it takes me with a wheelchair to the to the plane and it turns out I mean seat
所以现在我坐在轮椅上，等待航班，我试着去洗手间。当然，我试着去洗手间，当然我试着用轮椅去洗手间，而洗手间根本不是为任何坐轮椅的人设计的，我真的很沮丧，我真的很沮丧，因为洗手间不是为坐轮椅的人设计的。然后情况变得更糟了，
I don't know, 37D or something. And now how do I get to the seats? The wheelchair that they gave me was too wide for the seat, we couldn't go through it. So he now carries me on his back to seat 37D, which was fine, but this was a flight from New York to London. And now how do I get to the bathroom? So it's kind of clear to me that I need to stay in character. And I basically don't drink and I don't go to the bathroom.
因为接下来他用轮椅把我推到飞机上，结果证明我的座位是，我不知道，37D还是别的什么。现在我怎么去座位？他们给我的轮椅对座位来说太宽了，我们过不去。所以他现在背着我到37D座位，这很好，但这是一趟从纽约飞往伦敦的航班。现在我怎么去洗手间？所以对我来说很清楚，我需要保持这个角色。我基本上不喝水，也不去洗手间。
He carries me on his back as we land in London. And then I decide to go and complain to the people from Air India about how they're not treating people with disability. And you know what, I had in me the frustration of somebody who's actually on the wheelchair. I truly went into character. Maybe I should have been an actor. I truly went into character and I truly felt the humiliation of somebody who actually needs a wheelchair and the airline is just not doing the right thing. So, you know, this was like unbelievable ability to pretend I was something that I am not and very quickly
当我们降落在伦敦时，他背着我。然后我决定去找印度航空公司的人抱怨他们是如何对待残疾人的。你知道吗，我内心充满了真正坐在轮椅上的人的沮丧。我真的进入了角色。也许我应该当个演员。我真的进入了角色，我真的感受到了一个真正需要轮椅的人所受到的羞辱，而航空公司却没有做正确的事情。所以，你知道的，这就像是能够假装成我不是某种人的不可思议的能力，并且非常迅速地
get into the character and truly get upset and get upset over this. Now, just to say something in my own favor, in my own defense, if I may your honor, I know you're judging me now. And I think if I was not injured at all, it would have been tough for me to just make up something completely. But the fact that I kind of have some difficult standing,
进入角色，真正感到沮丧并为此沮丧。现在，为了说点对我有利的话，为了我自己的辩护，如果法官大人允许的话，我知道你现在在评判我。我想如果我根本没有受伤，要我凭空捏造一些东西可能会很艰难。但事实上我站立有些困难，
I have lots of burns on my legs, not that I deserve, I should need a wheelchair, but it was kind of an easier jump. And I think this is kind of the thing with the slippery slope that we see and this ability to justify our behavior in all kinds of creative ways. By the way, I should say one more thing.
我的腿上有许多烧伤，并不是说我应得的，我应该需要轮椅，但这是一种更容易的跨越。我认为这正是我们在滑坡效应中看到的那种情况，以及以各种创造性方式为我们的行为辩护的能力。顺便说一句，我应该再说一件事。
We find that when we look at personality tests of who cheats more, we thought maybe people who take more risks, maybe risk-takers cheat more. No, maybe intelligent people, no creative people cheat more. And why do creative people cheat more? Because cheating is all about being able to tell a story about why what we want is actually okay. And sadly, I think I'm creative. Dan Ariali, I want to thank you for joining me on Hidden Brain today. It was a pleasure even though you made me relive some a little bit humiliating moments, but I thank you for it.
我们发现，当我们查看谁更容易作弊的人格测试时，我们曾认为也许承担更多风险的人，也许冒险者作弊更多。不，也许聪明的人，不，有创造力的人作弊更多。为什么有创造力的人作弊更多？因为作弊全在于能够讲一个关于为什么我们想要的东西其实没问题的故事。可悲的是，我觉得我很有创造力。丹·艾瑞里，我要感谢你今天加入我的《隐藏的大脑》。这是一种荣幸，尽管你让我重温了一些有点屈辱的时刻，但我为此感谢你。
This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Penman and edited by Tara Boyer. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Path Shah, Laura Quarelle, Thomas Liu, Kat Schuchnacht and Lushikwaba. This week we're giving a shout out to two unsung heroes, our colleagues Patrick Cooper and Dan Newman. Dan and Patrick work on digital media at NPR. They have brought creativity, coding skills and patience to the Hidden Brain page at NPR.org. Thank you, Dan and Patrick, for all your hard work. For more Hidden Brain,
本期《隐藏的大脑》由玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）制作，塔拉·博耶（Tara Boyer）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、帕特·沙阿（Path Shah）、劳拉·夸雷勒（Laura Quarelle）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）、卡特·舒赫纳特（Kat Schuchnacht）和鲁什·夸巴（Lushikwaba）。本周我们要向两位无名英雄致敬，我们的同事帕特里克·库珀（Patrick Cooper）和丹·纽曼（Dan Newman）。丹和帕特里克在NPR负责数字媒体。他们为NPR.org上的《隐藏的大脑》页面带来了创造力、编码技能和耐心。谢谢你们，丹和帕特里克，感谢你们所有的辛勤工作。更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，
please follow us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们，并收听你在当地公共广播电台上的我的故事。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子发表评论。